you say there were 19 officers gathered
in the hallway or somewhere what efforts
were made to try and break through that
door you saved the spot
what else were the officers making to
try breaking into that door or another
door
get inside that classroom
none at that time
came in inside the classroom in 1203 and
you reached it at 12 51. how many
students died in those 48 minutes i
don't have that answer we're looking at
it right now
joining me now is chris swecker former
assistant fbi director and ashton pack
he's a retired sergeant for the los
angeles police department he was also
one of the responders to the 2017 mass
shooting at the los angeles or las vegas
concert
chris i want to start with you
evidently no efforts were made to open
that door
early on in the process
and we have no idea how many lives could
have been saved during that time
you're a professional you studied this
you've trained for this what's your
reaction
yeah i mean a lot of things went wrong
here
right from the very beginning the
security at the school you know
all kinds of different security flaws
there if they had their procedures in
place they sure certainly didn't
practice them so you know that's the
first line of defense the response is is
a different matter uh you know as as we
now know in in listening to steve mccraw
colonel mccraw do his press conference
as we now know they gathered you know
two officers went down
outside the door 19 officers gathered
outside and a decision was made to wait
now what we don't know is whether they
were in touch with dispatch you know the
9-1-1 center because if they were aware
that these people from inside the
children were calling from inside that
room then there is absolutely no excuse
it should have been the charge of the
light brigade they should have just kept
on going until they neutralized that
shooter because you know there are
survivors inside and he's still in there
with sporadic shooting so you know
you hate to make harsh judgments but i
think steve mccraw laid it on the line
today i you know i i know him and i he
has great integrity
note also that dps was not the
responding agency they are the
investigating agency so they only you
know they took what they were told and
then
ran with that for a couple of days i
think finally after two days the truth
comes out so
you know a lot of things went wrong here
but clearly
they should have gone in
sergeant pak you you've had a a long
career you studied and looked at these
things is one of the most horrific
shootings we've ever had in this country
but as you see it unfolding and limited
information that you have what's your
reaction
well thank you for having me and i agree
with the special agent and
honestly i want everyone to look at this
through two lenses don't paint all law
enforcement with a broad brush right now
there are heroes in that community
heroes in that police department
who rushed to gunfire and rushed in to
try and save lives now i think
ultimately what we need to find out is
what were what was the ideas and the
thoughts behind the decision of the
incident commander on the scene to treat
this as a hostage situation
it's best practices in our country and
we train in law enforcement and i
trained
when i was a police officer my the
officers under my purview
that anyone who's showing homicidal
intent
especially on the hallowed ground that
are our schools here in this country and
our children being our most precious
resource that we have
we have to rush in and we have to assume
that deadly force may be warranted we
can't treat this as a hostage situation
he was showing murderous intent it was
very evident from the shots he fired at
the two folks who were working at i
believe a cemetery or a funeral home
there was a collapse a breakdown of this
school being secured and leaving a door
open
how heartbreaking that is it's something
we've all done
but as school employees people who are
trained and to safeguard our children
this is something that we absolutely
have to think about of
just a simple act of locking a door and
having the entire campus on a lockdown
the minute anything blips that radar
outside that that could be an armed
assailant
chris i mean obviously the communication
will be something they can go back and
they'll have uh you know some forensics
on that and and the ability to
communicate with 19 officers inside
which was new information which we
didn't hear before um and the idea that
a teacher left the door open and there
is a school lockdown in place
i
i mean at what point do you just say my
goodness we this could have been
prevented
yeah it was preventable i mean i do
school security assessments and i see
this a lot
where you know they understand the rules
they're on the books the protocols are
there they're in a book sitting
gathering dust on the corner of the desk
but nobody actually puts them in
practice and you see time and time again
that that teachers will prop doors open
and
all i can say is you have to trust but
verify in this situation someone has to
come around
and and do a periodic assessment of the
school security i think there's only a
middle school of high school and an
elementary school in the county
and i don't think it's a whole lot to
ask that someone come around
periodically and do a third party
assessment to make sure that they're
following their own protocols because it
was in the books to keep everything
locked one point of entry during school
hours how to lock things down when
there's trouble how to communicate the
lockdown which is always the problem how
do you communicate the lockdown one
teacher knows to do it but how do you
get everybody knowing what to do so i
you know i i can't tell you how many
breakdowns there were on the front end
of this now law enforcement's got to
come out and clean up the mess
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else